welcome to this video this is again
Rick's on Gracie and all other guys
online here Rick's on Gracie JJ yeah we
had a king's indian and in the king
before that you know he goes home check
this line check which is so yeah I again
fairly solid but white is normally and
being able to keep a slight advantage
this is 11 key idea gaining some space
on the Kings side I'm taking that space
maybe maybe 9043 and probably doesn't
matter much the g 4g want is to make
sure f5 is not that effective wow not
effective at all
yeah I'm playing a bit quicker because I
I have that earlier game against him in
mind where we spend so much time and
interesting very non non standard kind
of mafia 95 now probably after there is
he's on f3 so maybe Bishop g2 especially
sex huh interesting age fries not great
either f was Knight f3
okay each floor goes back and I go to f1
goes to g6 mmm that's such a bad
position for him what about f4
immediately here at forum okay let's do
that okay well here i have f 5 sometimes
no not right now if i go see 5 you will
open up the long diagonal this is kind
of awkward it's a very very key position
in this game I have things like f5 that
are really interesting
keeping him pushing him back somehow and
tickets in at five I don't know we I
cannot recover that pawn still if I go
see five if I let's do normal moves for
once c5 takes a fall then he goes and
five he threaten you okay to wear this
is a really bad thing I'm not happy with
that move really I could really see
anything else like g6 he cannot supply
are you have f5 I think yeah come on f5
that that must be right here if not then
nothing I can do about it I think f5
immediately was better much better
actually the sugar for now is this is
very serious check okay i can i can
remove the king I mean this is hanging
can i'm the king is there some kind of
square be three years completely bonkers
now i have to change it now that share
check i roped his 74 bishop see seven
assists super dangerous if he goes to be
6 I mean super dangerous s probably too
little
I came like you for or Rookie one rookie
147 yeah come on 57 you should be
phaidor's rupee ate meat so now maybe
you can go look the aid and hold this
still no I still have rookie seven okay
i still have okay Sam I hope lucky seven
lucky one okay so look you 191 look 80
check Kings you three
there is God look H was some some weird
move
really be heartbreaking if you can
escape this right i mean i yes to all
get you i mean what what is the Y think
in here there's some other I don't see
any other move what time morning so I
can yeah it is a move that is a move
Bishop t6 or something
still cannot move that bishop
okay could you five possible no get to
write I was just just a better player
they don't see and a brother moves here
and please stop drilling I really hate
that and some some neighbor is drilling
I don't know do they really have changes
every day or something okay take this
check
thought you would take before maybe
so not easy
check
I'll stop the drilling check I
absolutely cannot play chess with sound
like that it's really terrible roop d7
now is this something check okay maybe I
can thinking of this end game here check
right let stupid [ __ ] like I cannot play
with this kind of noise really maybe I
can promote it this is just in time but
I didn't calculate this properly it was
just like hope chest a little bit now
I'm winning this amazing that was a
super lucky I mean okay maybe I'm losing
on time but check position I'm winning
Joachim I'm losing this this nonsense on
time for its to screw this and stop
drilling haha check check check
and I think at one point in one point he
had a very good position when when he
allowed my f5 that was just terrible
here yes to go and five himself of
course and then I'm in bad shape now the
bishop is playing and this is just a big
mistake allowing this and now I'm
winning but I couldn't really executed
properly is this ruji one who da 27 rook
a2 is indeed the best move but you
didn't do it and now this should be
three is winning listens check this and
also should win somehow Andrew gave
eight is better yeah I didn't play this
because of hook a check check but of
course yes I can do that here this is
better I'm winning winning a six prolly
okay yeah this is much better than this
check the way it turned out what was
again winning but check then we had the
drilling for chilling thing and empty
eight now is winning for zoosk one he
put himself in a zoosk volume what
Gaborik i couldn't really think anymore
that was impossible relief check this
this win I mean I'm not saying I would
have found it without the drilling but
with those salts I'm absolutely
incapable of thinking it's really I'm
very sensitive and then and now I'm
winning it funny enough it's it's it's a
window but to have sex six second let it
sit stupid known increment I'm yeah
anyway yeah yet which odds with f5 so it
was was interesting but the way it went
I really should have won and now I've
lost what three or four in a row with
the head of good positions okay well
thanks for watching